on a décidé de venir afin calyxis parce
que c'est une ville tranquille juste une
mule qui est parfaite pour nos enfants
un garçon quand on lui a dit ça il
pleurait il veut pas changer d'école il
y est bien le 90 familles de saint
calixte dont les logements appartiennent
au même propriétaire ont reçu ces
derniers jours un avis d'augmentation de
leur loyer les 78 ans et demi il veut
toutes les montées à 1350 $ et pour ceux
qui louent des maisons de ville le
montant est encore plus élevé quand on
est arrivés en 2019 y était à 1250
dollars mais ils venaient de l'augmenter
de 300 $ déjà on a signé ensuite ils
nous ont augmenté de 200 dollars et puis
ce qui fait 1450 dehors puis là il nous
a demandé 400 dollars ce qui fait 1850
ce que ces immeubles ont en commun c'est
qu'ils ont été construits il ya moins de
cinq ans ce qui permet aux propriétaires
d'imposer la hausse de loyer qu'ils
désirent en fonction d'une clause dans
la section f dubai est où la logique
pourquoi pourquoi nous augmenter autant
alors que dans le fond il ne fait aucune
réparation
le propriétaire a refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue il justifie les
augmentations par la hausse du coût des
matériaux et celle du marché on purpose
re logique 90 familles à saint calixte
impossible
dans la municipalité de 6000 citoyens
ses propriétaires immobiliers possède 84
des 119 logements disponibles soit 70 %
de tout le parc locatif donc de
retrouver des cinq ennemis à l'extérieur
de ce taux propriétaire là il y en a pas
beaucoup pour les ménages concernés il
existe des recours judiciaires mais
limité il ya des jurisprudences au
tribunal admistratif du logement qui
disent que les augmentations sont
illégitimes qui est moyen mais faut 13
buts en attendant les locataires ont un
mois pour répondre à l'avis
d'augmentation
ça représente devoir aller dans le plus
petit on veut rester et refuser
l'augmentation sous saint pio l'année
parfois on a déménagé mon conjoint puis
mois seulement avec les cinq enfants je
ne me vois pas faire ça ça n'est
vraiment pas ici julie et mon radio
canada saint calixte